hemos visto ya muchos ejemplos de series
infinitas pero lo emocionante de este
vídeo es que vamos a usar series
infinitas para definir una función y la
más común que verás en toda tu carrera
matemática es la serie de potencias muy
bien serie de potencias entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es definir una función
efe de x este es fx y la vamos a
expresar como una serie de la siguiente
forma vamos a calcular la suma desde
cero hasta infinito de ciertos
coeficientes a n que multiplican a x
menos c elevado a la n entonces a lo
mejor ya en tu cabeza estará gritando
algo que te dice que se parece mucho a
las series que hemos estado viendo y
vamos a desarrollarlas un poco para que
veas cómo se ve esto será para cuando n
es cero tendremos a cero que multiplica
a x menos c elevado a la cero que eso es
una verdad simplemente nos quedaría un
número
a 0 luego sumamos a 1 que multiplica a x
menos elevado a la 1 y seguimos sumando
a 2 que multiplica a x menos elevado al
cuadrado y así podemos seguir sumando
muy bien entonces como podrás darte
cuenta de seguro estarás diciendo que
esto se parece a una serie geométrica y
de hecho lo más probable es que ya estés
viendo que la serie geométrica es un
caso particular de la serie de potencias
porque porque la serie geométrica vamos
a vamos a recordar la serie geométrica
la serie geométrica lo podemos también
expresar digamos de la siguiente forma
la suma desde
n igual a cero hasta infinito de un
nuestro primer término que multiplica a
x a la n donde x sería nuestra
proporción común entonces si lo vemos de
esta forma como que x es una variable
independiente
esto es una función ésta es una función
g x muy bien donde x es nuestra variable
independiente cuando cuando nosotros
hacíamos series geométricas aquí
poníamos una r verdad la rd de éste para
representar la proporción común pero en
este caso es una equis que es es una
variable independiente muy bien entonces
no es forzoso poner x puede ser una
función que depende de r pero bueno es
es lo más común poner a x como una
variable independiente y esto quien
sería cuando n vale 0 tenemos a por x a
la 0
por equis al hacer o más
cuando n vale 1 es a por x a la uno más
cuando en el vale 2 sería a por x al
cuadrado y así seguimos sumando hasta el
infinito verdad entonces la gran
diferencia aquí es simplemente que
nuestros coeficientes a n en la serie
geométrica son siempre el mismo y es un
número fijo a verdad y aquí bueno
estaríamos pensando que la c vale 0
verdad simplemente aquí arriba lo puedes
ver como que estamos desplazando nos
recorriendo no sé unidades
ahora bien bajo ciertas condiciones
nosotros sabemos que la serie geométrica
con bergé a un valor verdad sabemos que
siempre que la proporción común tenga
valor absoluto menor que 1
esto será igual a nuestro primer término
dividido entre uno menos la proporción
común muy bien entonces sabemos que esto
con bergé entonces convergen
con bergé
y el valor absoluto de x de la
proporción común es menor que 1 o en
otras palabras esto ocurre si x es menor
que 1 pero más grande que menos 1 muy
bien así que aquí x puede variar dijimos
que era una variable independiente y
definimos una función en términos de
esta serie que es una serie geométrica
esta serie tiene sentido es decir
convergen siempre que nos encontremos
con valores de x mayores que menos 1 y
menores que 1 así que esto de aquí no se
está definiendo un intervalo de hecho
pueden pensar este intervalo así el
menos 1 a candar el 0 y a quien da el 1
en este intervalo vamos a poder
garantizar que la función converge ya s
le vamos a llamar intervalo de
convergencia justamente es el intervalo
en donde la función converge muy bien y
entonces
esto ocurre cuando tenemos esto de aquí
entonces este valor tiene sentido muy
bien
entonces lo que necesitamos es que
nuestra proporción común que en nuestro
caso en nuestro caso será x verdad aquí
para multiplicar a multiplicamos por x
para poder obtener el siguiente término
y luego multiplicamos por x para obtener
el siguiente término entonces nuevamente
por si no había quedado claro x es como
nuestra proporción común pero además es
variable aquí aquí aquí me equivoqué de
verdad no no es r aquí justamente
entonces es x entonces fíjate muy bien
que fue lo que ocurrió tenemos una serie
que nos definió esta función y esta es
una función muy bonita a entre 1 - x
entonces podemos desarrollar funciones
tradición tradicionales en series
geométricas tiene esto tiene muchas
aplicaciones en ciencia y en ingeniería
por ejemplo cuando queremos aproximar
cierta función podemos decir bueno esta
función la podemos expresar en una serie
de potencias o en una serie geométrica
entonces podemos quedarnos con algunos
términos que nos ayuden a manipularlos o
simplemente los términos que no
cerebro puede entender por ejemplo que
nos queremos hasta este término es una
aproximación de esta función ok ahora
bien otro concepto que deberíamos y
remarcando es el siguiente es el
concepto de radio de convergencia radio
de convergencia y este este es un
concepto muy sencillo sin aquí aquí
nosotros decimos que las equis que se
encuentren en este intervalo son en
donde la función o más bien la serie
convergen a esta función de x que
resultó ser a entre 1 - x ahora que
tanto nos podemos alejar del 0 y decir
que si nos alejamos de ese 0 cierta
cantidad podemos garantizar que converge
a pues del 0 al o más nos podemos alejar
1 en ambos sentidos así que el radio de
convergencia es 1 y es el radio digamos
del intervalo muy bien ahora otra forma
de pensarlo es este este intervalo tiene
longitud
verdad aquí lleva una unidad y luego
otra unidad cuál es el radio pues la
mitad de esa longitud muy bien puedes
incluso hacer como la similitud con
círculos así que mientras no nos
alejamos de cero más del radio de
convergencia que en este caso es 1 esta
serie
convergen